ouf l'évacuation des civils à marioupol
à l'instant reporter annonce du maire de
la ville portuaire sous blocus de
l'armée russe le cessez le feu
temporaire n'a pas été respectée selon
lui des couloirs humanitaires doivent
pourtant se mettre en place les deux
tiers des 420 mille habitants n'ont pas
fui malgré les bombardements permanent
déterminé à résister marioupol est une
ville stratégique car elle permet à
moscou d'assurer une continuité
territoriale entre la crimée les forces
pro russes du dombass bruno daroux les
corridors humanitaires vont-ils être
mises en place seront ils respectés pour
l'instant c'est à reporter les vacations
de mario poil écouter malheureusement
c'est toujours un peu le problème avec
les corridors humanitaires
c'est à dire que pour qu'un corridor
humanitaire fonctionne il faut d'abord
qu'il est évidemment des négociations
entre deux belligérants donc là ça a été
le cas lors du deuxième round de
négociations il faut déjà se mettre
d'accord sur le principe de corridors
humanitaires mais la mise en place et la
mise en oeuvre de corridors humanitaires
évidemment ne nécessite d'abord que les
armes se taisent et qu'il y ait un
cessez-le-feu et c'est là souvent que
les difficultés commencent on l'a vu en
d'autres endroits notamment syrie par
exemple donc là visiblement c'est le cas
concernant donc l'évacuation de civils
de marioupol puisque un corridor
humanitaire ou s'il faut le rappeler
permet à la fois dans un sens de faire
sortir les civils qui le souhaitent d'un
endroit à siéger évidemment on est
toujours en terrain de guerre forcément
et al'inverse de faire rentrer des
vivres des médicaments du matériel
humanitaire de manière plus générale
donc après la condition sinequanone
c'est que vraiment le cas de le dire
c'est le cessez le feu et quand il n'est
pas respectée et bien évidemment le
couloir ne peut pas fonctionner donc
c'est toujours quand même une très forte
précarité qui règne sur ces au dessus du
de ces corridors humanitaires sur le sur
la remise en oeuvre parce que évidemment
quand on est dans un conflit il ya
toujours des unités qui peuvent désobéir
d'un côté ou de l'autre et donc les
cessez le feu sont quand même très dur à
fait respecté que c'est toujours la
difficulté pour les corridors
humanitaires on va écouter le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky
sur 12 mois les gens qui mourront à
partir de maintenant nous aurons à cause
de vous à cause de votre faiblesse à
cause de votre désunion
aujourd'hui les dirigeants de l'alliance
atlantique ont donné le feu vert à la
poursuite des bombardements des villes
et villages ukrainien en refusant de
mettre en place une zone d'exclusion
dans le président ukrainien là des mots
très durs contre l'otan et les pays
occidentaux
oui elle a malheureusement on est on est
au coeur de cette très très difficile
équation ukrainienne c'est à dire que
oui quand on entend le président
zelensky alors que son pays est agressé
par une armée très très moderne très
équipée qui a une supériorité énorme sur
les forces du creden même s'il y a une
résistance quand même admirable de la
part d'une grande population d'une
grande partie de la population oui bien
sûr on a envie de dire mais oui bien sûr
il faut y aller il faut faire cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne pour porter une
aide directe à cette armée ukrainienne
notamment dans le ciel et mettre fin au
contrôle total du ciel par les
l'aviation russe bien sûr mais
évidemment l'autre termes de l'équation
qui fait qu'elle est quasiment pas par
les halls wable si vous voulez c'est que
les occidentaux savent très bien que
s'ils font ça on entre en confrontation
directe avec la russie et que là
franchement ça peut si vous me passez
l'expression partir en sucette c'est à
dire que là tout le monde danse à
bruxelles c'est une expression mal ont
mal à propos en fait mais les choses
peuvent déraper très très sérieusement
et après on peut comprendre la logique
2nd ce qui lui ce qui l'intéresse c'est
de sauver son pays son régime
éventuellement sa personne mais en tout
cas d'épargné le maximum de vies civiles
en ukraine donc lui joue c'est la survie
de l'ukraine donc évidemment il emploie
tous les moyens y compris une forme de
pression morale et en face des
occidentaux disent bon on vous accordez
au maximum une aide indirecte via des
sanctions bien la fourniture d'armement
daide humanitaire
malheureusement on ne peut pas aller
plus loin et c'est c'est vraiment je
pense un crève coeur pour beaucoup de
dirigeants que de ne pas pouvoir aller
plus loin mais eux les occidentaux
l'otan notamment et les américains aussi
savent que leur souci eux c'est de
préserver tant que faire se peut la
mienne mondiale et malheureusement c'est
vrai que dans cette affaire là le dégât
collatéral enfin si j'ose dire ça risque
fort d'être l'ukraine c'est à dire que
l'ukraine risquent fort d'être sacrifiée
sur l'autel d'une paix mondiale tant
qu'elle peut demeurer en l'état sachant
qu'on plus vu tous les tous les
changements de plaques presque
tectoniques est en train de produire
cette crise la gérance j'écoutais
bertrand badie qui en parler avec vous
il y à quelques minutes voilà tout est
tellement incertain qu'en fait les
occidentaux se disent au moins ça là on
n'y va pas parce que là franchement ça
peut partir dans tous les sens merci
beaucoup bruno daroux merci à vous plus